[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world in
pop culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather roof and on Diana wave and
this is your news for Monday January 8th
first up this week we officially have
our Sabrina cash all right now that
Netflix has picked it up a not CW
Sabrina will now be played by Kiernan
Shipka who is also chi me me me on Kimmy
Schmidt if you watch that show as well
as on Mad Men yeah so I'm expecting good
things from her that's gonna be exciting
however is now that Netflix has it and
not CW Riverdale is in the same universe
and God is still on CW so will there
still be a crossover and I will network
I hope so I mean Sabrina is obviously a
part of the Archie comics world so to
have her not somehow associate with
Riverdale would be a pretty odd choice
and I was under the impression that it's
gonna be kind of the same energy kind of
the same style dark moody brooding Oh
God Riverdale along my way I should flip
it but I do
but yeah so now Sabrina has been cast
officially officially officially because
we have announced a casting before Brad
is Cameron was initially a part of the
project or supposedly a part of the
project but then when it moved to
Netflix I dove Cameron I got my I don't
know yeah she was a fan favorite for
that but I really think here and can
bring a lot to the role for sure yeah
that's gonna be super interesting so
that'll be on Netflix also this week
sci-fi picked up a full 10 episodes
season of George RR Martin's sci-fi
novella called night fliers so this is
going to be set on like kind of like a
like a haunted spaceship a crew
exploring for alien life in space you
know spaceship obviously
and it's going to be on Netflix
internationally so but in the u.s. it's
going to be airing on sci-fi so this
sounds really cool it sounds kind of a
little bit goofy uh and yeah there's
gonna be a whole a whole season of that
ten episodes it will be shooting in
Ireland but it has all of its cast and
everything is moving forward so we can
look forward to a full season effects
yeah and george RR martin is going to be
one of the executive producers right so
we'll see if it means it's gonna stay
close to the book novella right or if
it's gonna depart pretty fast it sounded
like from what I read he's gonna be
stepping back and letting the production
and take over it but look forward to a
lot of death with george RR mark yeah
this week we got a ton of trailers we're
gonna focus on just a couple um the
first one that was a little baffling to
me is we got a trailer for Slender Man
which is about you guessed it
Slender Man which just seems like an odd
choice it's a little distasteful after
the events of the stabbings that the
stabbing that happened in 2014 and in
fact the parents of those children have
already come out and said like we are
not on board with this there's a little
import taste for us it also just seems
like the Slenderman popularity boat has
kind of passed sailed it's it's gone so
I'm really not sure what is gonna happen
with this movie and the tone of it even
seems very odd I'm not sure if it's
going to be a straight-up horror film
like a traditional kind of b-movie
horror film with some weird things
happening or if it's going to focus more
on the psychological element of what's
happening with some of these youths
youth because it is focusing on a group
of teenagers who are doing some creepy
weird things and it's not clear from the
trailer whether it's a Slenderman as
real and coming to get them or if it is
all in their head because for something
titled Slenderman we only saw Slenderman
for maybe two seconds yeah
maybe two second it's
names kind of almost Freddy Krueger II
too because it seems like only a couple
people were seeing it or being affected
by it at least we saw them writing on
mirror that's in the trailer I'm sure we
can expect a lot more gory right sure
yeah I'm sure and that's not gonna come
out though until May of 2018 mm-hmm so
we got a little bit to see some more of
it
to see if it's gonna be great or awful
who's to say it's gonna be scary though
so will it on another trailer this week
that we got it's game over man takes a
bit of a different term and it's going
to be an action comedy by the
workaholics crew and it looks hilarious
it opens with Shaggy being held hostage
and having to sing was me looks very
very funny they have a gun fight but not
in the way that you think they just
shoot towards each other I'm not
actually into each other right it just
looks like classic workaholics humor and
dumb funny just high-stakes looks
hilarious and that's actually coming out
on Netflix yeah
in March March 23rd we can look forward
to that so I'm actually really looking
forward to the workaholics guys being
back now so it's gonna be very exciting
some very very exciting news that we got
this weekend guys guys it's time for the
main yeah yes okay it's coming back it's
happening we're getting two new seasons
of it yeah straight to streaming on Hulu
however y'all are gonna have to wait
okay it's not gonna come out until 2020
my gut reaction to this is that I'm
excited I loved Animaniacs when I was a
kid and I'm very excited but then I'm
also a little weird a little curious you
know
good it could just be a cash grab we've
seen things come back and not do it
right we've seen things come back and do
well right so so what's up in the air
right now but I think if it is just a
cash grab then you're totally missing
the whole tone and points of animation
yeah so I'm still excited about it I
think it's gonna be good
I'm just excited to see more adventures
of Yakko Wakko and dot I'm gonna see
them come back but if you're as excited
about I am and getting pumped about it
what do we do right now yeah right now
you can go to Hulu because they got the
whole library rights for Animaniacs so
if you go to Hulu right now you can
watch all of it you can also watch all
of Pinky and the brain and tiny toons so
don't get busy till 2020 yes again it's
not gonna happen until 2020 at least
that's when its projected to come out
because with an animated series like
this you got it have time oh yeah the
animation so I'm sure we'll be hearing
plenty of news about casting and who's
gonna be involved with the writing
process of animating process and how
it's gonna be animated it's gonna be
like who knows here's a weird thought
about it though we reported a couple
weeks ago that Disney now owns a
controlling share of Hulu so does that
mean that Disney is partially
controlling the Animaniacs and well they
by 2020 right yeah that's that's just
wrong it's straight that's just strange
and wrong so that's an odd thought to
put in there as well that might be a
part of the mix of this news but I'm
still excited cuz I love anime yeah and
I'm probably gonna go home and watch
more of it yeah I don't know probably
will yeah I love it
first exciting and I'm sure a lot of you
feel the same way there's a lot of
nostalgia I feel associated with
Animaniacs so I'm sure there's gonna be
some of you watching it with me let's do
this when we get back let's just watch
some animating also this week we got a
fun little announcement from Dark Horse
as well as Mantic games that there's
going to be a Hellboy
board game
which I think sounds awesome especially
since it's going to be a co-op game okay
so that means that it's not gonna be
player versus player it's going to be
all the players working together to
defeat some of the big bads Colette are
a part of the Hellboy Universe and it's
only going to be for up to four players
but I think that's because they want to
keep the main core group of the Hellboy
concert as the characters that you can
play and it seems like it's going to
have a lot of interesting components to
it
they've already teased that there's
going to be some great minifigs
associated with high quality minifigs so
of course you can actually physically
play with the help like characters there
the only thing is that this is going to
be a Kickstarter right it hasn't
officially been funded or anything yet
so look for it on Kickstarter in April
of 2018
so we have that to look forward to and
I'm probably right so we have the right
so it's gotta be there obviously talking
to distributors if they already know
that they're going to have these high
quality minifigs associated with it so
it's going to be something to look
forward to coming out in April 2018 on
Kickstarter though look out for the
Mantic games Kickstarter page awesome
well that's gonna be it from us we had
tons more trailers this week that we
couldn't even get to right just let us
know in the comments down below what we
missed or what we should look forward to
next week when we see you otherwise you
can get us on social media haven't read
that for you you can find me on Twitter
at Heather ruse Instagram at H ruse or
twitch twitch TV slash Heather ruse and
as always you can find me on Facebook as
I on await or everywhere else as awesome
Ayana
let us know in the comments down below
what we should look forward to otherwise
we
[Applause]
you